J'ai
posté sur par beau
euh
mais je yep bluh bluh bluh bluh
hahaha c'est un bleu tu sais ce qu'on passe est
très très la preuve d'accord pour toi Peter ouais
j'ai fini d'accord merci d'accord revenons
euh oh wow revenons juste rouler la photo
comme  un garçon jouets
Oh
tu suis la ligne remarque cent
onze heures d'
accord alors d'accord d'accord arrête de regarder à travers les
redbones rétroaction négative venant à
travers les sacs de glace nous allons nous
déplacer pouvons-nous revenir au bon moment
ouais d'accord ou lentement nous même  sans par
sans c'est bien d'accord je veux le tirer
pour parler récupérer ok je c'est bien quand tu l'
obtiens quand un flic Aquino
ils descendent ok nous allons vs ouais ok
c'est bien de le fermer jusqu'à environ
toi sur ce plateau sur notre on veut celui-ci
ok
tu vois ça comme eux être gentils ici
suis celui des vêtements
après coup bilité comment tu veux le
faire p te dire toi toi tu te prends trois
voeux tu vas de la siroque  enregistrement ok
vous le faites en dessous réservez l'énergie
trois pieds  non les gars ok est-ce que ça regarde
où nous sommes vous religieux il y a
bien ok ça va être les petites joies
aussi tout d'abord je pense que c'est plus
beau ici
hé arrête
hé les trucs
ok ne fais pas celui-ci est un autre qui
arrive maintenant alors  nous pouvons faire est-il être acheminé
pas trop sûr faites attention à cela ne soyez pas
trop trop et aussi un certain temps vous pouvez mettre
le bateau dessus sur un nœud au milieu
du cadre vous pouvez le faire sur le
coin vous  savez ce que je veux dire planète oui
monsieur
vous
pour moi à la [ __ ] de gauche d'accord s'il vous plaît d'
accord arrêtez d'
accord nous suivons les yeux là-bas en train de
construire au-dessus d'avant moi parce que je pense que
vous deux aussi parfaits un clochard aujourd'hui est de retour
sur les safaris photo oscillateur
j'ai
quelque temps dans  Afrique, vous trouverez quelqu'un
dans un tizzy et accompli là-bas avec
les fils sont secs, vous avez l'air
d'être
tout à fait à onze heures,
mais demain vous, les banquiers,
ralentissez simplement la vitesse de l'air lorsque
nous nous rapprochons,
je suis  incroyable incroyable belle
tu
vas chercher j'en ai un de plus  e cercle
endroit un fils arrive maintenant booyaka ouais je l'
ai compris
préparez-vous à être un barbier est comme celui-ci
qui prend soin de vous et de la glace prend des choses comme
ça c'est bien pour moi aussi
je reçois tortola je sais ce que tu veux dire mais
nous devons  prends un surf blanc toi
sinon sympa sympa beau mon dieu
c'est fantastique tu gagnes le fœtus c'est
incroyable avec des choses comme un oiseau tu
continues de revenir encore une fois nous aurons à
nouveau la réflexion la prochaine fois oh
c'est comme voler ta pensée que
c'est beau que les autres s'en éloignent un peu
mais c'est Nora totalement
dans le carburant mais tu gagnes ce coup de poing
obtiendra aussi mon ami ouais je dis que nous
prenons un sage si je sais que tu fais de ton mieux
maintenant c'est juste quand nous sommes dedans  le vent
nous fait reculer donc nous payons un cercle plus sage
dans ce parc c'est pourquoi si
tout va bien ou si vous avez un peu de ce goooo
pas de problème d'accord ouais nous allons le prendre un
peu plus large ici oh si vous tournez maintenant
il va être  baisé aussi bon
parce que ce n'est pas le cas  Je ne me soucie pas d'une
série mais c'est mieux pour Peter Rezza
va jeter tes pieds ouais je veux avoir
le scintillement j'ai le reflet qui
passe Oh allez allez allez allez allez allez n'importe quand
sur celui-ci, je veux voir un joli
sac va être vivant nous allons faire un simple
équipier remonter le moral vous êtes les bienvenus eh
bien c'était un peu différent d'
accord, d'accord, arrêtez d'enregistrer de